commander mcgrath one of the most
influential members of mobile task force
alpha one better known as the red right
hand had been summoned by his masters
for one of the most important missions
of his life it was so above top secret
even he would likely need to undergo
amnesic treatment once he'd seen the job
through it comes with a territory when
you're dealing with scp-006
the red right hand is no ordinary mobile
task force either they were the personal
enforcers of the o5 council the 13 most
powerful members of the scp foundation
and by extension some of the most
powerful human beings on earth commander
mcgrath stood before the assembled
council trying to suppress the tremors
of fear and awe running through him he'd
gone toe-to-toe with scp-076
abel one of the finest humanoid warriors
ever known during one of his many
containment breaches he led strike
forces after a fleeing scp-682
the hard-to-destroy reptile after it
escaped its acid tank and began charging
towards the nearest populated area
intent on causing mass death he'd
personally taken out more people than
you've probably ever met all at the
behest of his foundation superiors and
yet standing right here before them he
couldn't help feel a twinge of deep
terror it was like staring right into
the face of god and waiting for it to
blink
with his well-honed military observation
skills he noted that 05-2 wasn't among
the council this time but he knew better
than to ask why he was employed to take
orders not to ask questions and this
time his orders were something special
he wasn't given any more information
than this mcgrath we need you to lead an
elite team to a striker in russia on the
double procedure 006 is now in effect
you know what to do mcgrath nodded he'd
been prepared for this day his
predecessor commander richards had only
needed to enact procedure 006 once in
his long and storied career with the red
right hand it was truly a once
once-in-a-lifetime assignment and now
the torch had been passed to him the
only question was whether he'd be up to
the task but mcgrath didn't have time to
ponder on this question time was of the
essence first he needed to assemble a
team small but focused loyal men who'd
keep their heads down complete the
mission and take the forbidden knowledge
no further than the bounds of said
mission mcgrath selected three
operatives bennett dimaggio and stuart
all of whom had proven valuable assets
in prior missions they would be the ones
to accompany him on this most valuable
and secretive of directives procedure
006
but before they could execute the
mission itself they needed to be trained
briefed and fitted with the proper
equipment for mission this sensitive and
dealing with an anomaly as deadly as
scp-006 they needed to wear modified
class 6 bnc suits these are the ultimate
total exclusion hazmat suits designed
specifically by the scp foundation they
offered such a degree of protection that
they made regular hazmat suits look like
bikinis commander mcgrath actually knew
very little about scp-006
and how it worked like many of the more
top-secret anomalies contained by the
foundation only the o5 council
understood the full scope of it everyone
below them were only told the specific
fragments of information they needed to
do their job after all filling your head
with the wrong kinds of knowledge can
get your memory wiped or worse at the
scp foundation
scp-006 as far as commander mcgrath knew
was the more traditional kind of toxic
he'd been briefed using the scp-006-b
info pack a heavily redacted description
of scp-006
safe class liquid in nature but one of
the most toxic substances known to man
it made mercury and uranium look like a
glass of mineral water and more
dangerous still if someone came into
contact with even the tiniest quantity
of
scp-006's liquids they would not only be
marked for certain death
they would also become a vector for
transmission a veritable plague rat a
walking danger to all mankind that's why
the class 6 bnc suits needed to be
tested mcgrath bennett dimaggio and
stuart suited up in a secure foundation
training facility and fully submerged
themselves in a training pool this was
how they made sure that there were no
vulnerabilities in the suits if any
bubbles were generated it meant there
was a leak and if there was a leak then
the person wearing the defective suit
was as good as dead when they reached
the real zero zero six lucky for them no
leaks they were ready to proceed to the
next stage of the mission
making their way to astrakhan russia
where
scp-006 was contained the pressure was
on with the council growing more
impatient by the moment so they needed
to make the journey immediately every
minute counted and commander mcgrath was
painfully aware of the time slipping
away though he couldn't possibly fathom
why they need a toxic chemical like this
with such urgency they made their
journey in a covert cargo plane it was
beyond important to keep all foundation
activity around
scp-006 under wraps a number of groups
of interest cells were active in the
area including the church of the broken
god and the serpent's hand and if ever
the dreaded chaos insurgency caught wind
of
scp-006's existence and triangulated its
location the damage it could do would be
unprecedented that's why nobody but the
o5 council could truly be trusted with
this almost sacred knowledge when they
touched down in the strakan they met
with a foundation courier who would take
them on the final leg of their journey
to the foundation site roughly 60
kilometers west of the town mcgrath and
his team had no idea what they were
headed towards or the insane history of
the land they traversed all because of
scp-006
the foundation had first become aware of
the anomaly back during the 19th century
but were unable to gain control of it
until 1991
due to it being fiercely guarded by a
procession of territorial russian rulers
the blood of hundreds of thousands had
been spilled on this land in the
historic wars and conflicts over scp-006
so many had wasted their entire lives
unsuccessfully trying to find it during
the several hour car trip to the site
commander mcgrath had no idea of the
true value of the anomaly he and his
small team were heading towards but he
would in time though an innocent would
have to die first the courier dropped
the four operatives off outside an
abandoned chemical plant in the styx far
from what anyone would call civilization
it was the kind of industrial decay you
could expect in the badlands of rural
russia a huge complex weathered and
broken by time but what the untrained
observer wouldn't realize is that the
plant was actually full of heavily
trained and even more heavily armed
foundation security personnel as
mcgrath's team approached the building
they had no less than eight sniper
rifles pointed at them from various
vantage points within the plant just to
be safe the foundation couldn't afford
to take any chances with scp-006
they arrived at the gate and provided
their clearance credentials they were
envoys here on behalf of the o5 council
themselves and if they weren't allowed
to complete their mission then the 006
personnel would have the death of a
council member on their hands with that
the team was given a free pass into the
site under close observation anyone
seeking to interface
scp-006 was forced to do so under almost
microscopic scrutiny even when inside
the building mcgrath and his men needed
to pass multiple secure checkpoints
throughout the halls each time restating
their security credentials eventually
they reached a different section of the
building foreboding anomalous hallways
gave way to what seemed like a mix of a
garden and a jungle but the plants were
different the trees the shrubs even the
weeds were unlike anything members of
the team had ever seen before it was
like stepping into an alien world or
perhaps this world but as it was a few
million years prior it was terrifying
and wondrous they suited up in their
class 6 bnc suits fearing airborne
contaminants from
scp-006 before proceeding further they
walk through this new jungle being
watched at every turn by security
cameras and personnel posted throughout
this overgrown portion of the facility
it didn't take long for them to reach
their destination the legendary scp-006
a small natural spring jutting out of a
rock surrounded by rich emerald grass it
looked more like a nice place to have a
picnic than a dangerous and highly
secretive anomaly but mcgrath wasn't
paid to question things only to carry
out procedures006
the only object they had with them was
the quad sealant container an ultra
secure liquid containment units
specifically designed for safely
transporting samples of
scp-006's water between sites the team
members descended into the spring and
began filling up the container it was
nerve-racking knowing the stakes of
their mission and knowing that they were
submerged in such a deadly substance
that they had a job to do and they were
going to do it come hell or high water
they filled the containment unit but
sadly for mcgrath and his team the
mission wouldn't be entirely without
casualty a single bubble rose from the
leg of stuart's suit he was a good mtf
operative but the youngest and least
experienced member of the team his suit
must have somehow been damaged during
transit and now he was compromised he
shared a haunting glance with mcgrath
and his fellow team members knowing that
his part of the mission and his life was
about to come to a swift and violent end
alarms rang out across the facility a
huge team of armed operatives all
wearing class six bnc suits charged into
the room stewart was grabbed and
manhandled out of the zero zero six
spring while his fellow team members
sealed the containment unit and
continued their mission there was no
time to stop rest or mourn completing
the mission was the absolute priority if
mcgrath understood the protocol as well
as he thought he did stuart would be
dragged into a secure room by the site's
staff and locked in with a blast door he
would look down and notice the floor
below him was a metal grate caked with
ash his last thoughts as the incinerator
launches its flames into action would
strangely be the fact that he was
feeling the healthiest he'd been in
years but that wouldn't stop the sudden
furnace around him from decimating his
body and leaving little more than ash
and charred bones over a decade of loyal
mtf service ended in an instant stewart
would have been terminated according to
orders from the top it was all that
could be done for those afflicted by
scp-006
a mercy really if they were to be
believed mcgrath and his team soldiered
on after retrieving the sample they were
hurried back into their inception point
one of the many classified bases
occupied by the o5 council members while
dimaggio and bennett were ushered off to
be given amnestic treatment mcgrath
would personally get to see the
containment unit and its precious cargo
make the final leg of the journey he was
going to be granted access 205-2
the person this had all been in service
of commander mcgrath approached the
secure quarters of the council member
escorted by a bevy of heavily armed
security personnel the doors open and he
saw her there 05-2
bedridden laying at the center of a
grand web of life-saving technology she
was beyond old and decrepit commander
mcgrath could see the sentries she'd
endured written deeply in the wrinkles
and scars of her ancient face she didn't
look like one of the most powerful
people in the world she looked like one
of the most feeble her eyes lit up when
mcgrath entered the room holding the
containment unit she beckoned him closer
until he was close enough for her to
take the containment unit from him with
scarred trembling hands mcgrath watched
in horror as she disengaged the lid and
swigged down the entirety of its
contents but wasn't the water toxic he
thought mcgrath had been fed the same
lie as everybody else the foundation
didn't keep 006 such a well-guarded
secret because it was capable of
bringing death quite the opposite in
fact all commander mcgrath could do was
stare awestruck as the years seemed to
fall from 05-2's face decades and
decades and decades scars faded wrinkles
disappeared little by little 05-2 began
to sit and then stand by the time she
was straightening her clothes she looked
like a healthy woman in her mid-40s it
was a complete and total transformation
the liquid of scp-006 has a plethora of
benefits to human subjects the ability
to regenerate damaged dna by heightened
excitement of cellular duplication and
producing a frightening increase in the
effectiveness of the human immune system
even upon testing the liquid on animal
subjects hostile bacteria and viral
agents were destroyed immediately
members of the o5 council are experts at
cheating death and
scp-006 is just another ace hidden up
their sleeve in the endless battle
against the reaper a secret so well
guarded that they're willing to
terminate even their most loyal servants
to keep it safe after all if everyone
knew about it everyone would want it and
the 05 council are very invested in
exclusivity never normally one to rise
above his station commander mcgrath
couldn't help blurt out but if it was
all lie private stewart is perfectly
alive all smoking mirrors you see and
like everyone who works a zero zero six
mission he won't remember a thing good
work commander mcgrath 05-2 now in
perfect health replied now return to
your post after a visit to our boys and
amnestics there's still plenty to be
done and we can't afford to dilly dally
after all you're not getting any younger
now go check out secret group that runs
the world scp-05 council explained and
how to work at the scp foundation
explain for more of the foundation's
most classified inner workings